well downtown Las Vegas also slowly
coming back to life when the clock hit
midnight crowds were right there on
Fremont Street hitting the casinos and
that's where we find Joe Moller and Joe
what are people saying out there tonight
there a lot of people are very excited
to be out here on the Fremont Street
Experience many people have been waiting
months for this day for all this to get
back open take a live look behind us
here there's a small crowd here people
walking up and down the street here just
taking a look of everything happy to get
back out here but as we know a night
time is when this book gets busy so I'm
sure within a few hours a lot more
people will be out and well last night
people flocks got so many of these
casinos at midnight when they opened up
for more than two months this area has
been closed now the only convince
attorney R now but also people who come
back to work today we ran into several
locals who said they were happy to be
here for the first day back
it feels great because we are one and
this is what it's about it's about
getting out supporting our people
supporting our businesses
and that's what we're gonna continue to
do come down here support
I just spent over $200 today that I
didn't need spend just to help support
my fellow bartenders in this industry as
far as social distancing on Fremont
people say they are noticing people
keeping their distance from one another
and some are wearing their masks for
safety reasons there are some
restrictions on Fremont visitors must be
21 to enter in that bags and purses are
prohibited now back out here live we're
taking a look at that canopy we are
noticing that they are asking people
here on the street to keep their
distance and their labeling another few
other safety protocol people to do there
but overall before just excited to be
back
sweet experiences
have some fun discussion with everything
they've been seeing
[Music]
I'll set it back to you